hey what is up guys my name is a channel
woged episode 31 of game programming so
on episode 30 last time we took a look
at actually I keep opening the game as
if we've changed the thing but we
haven't um well we have really we've
done the most important part and that's
that that does like the behind the
scenes work now what we did last time
was we basically used this random method
in the grass style class to actually
render a child you know to the screen
basically just apply it we haven't
actually rendered anything physically to
the screen yet but we've we've laid down
the groundwork the framework for it and
that's that's really important now I
know that a lot of you guys are actually
wondering you know we haven't actually
changed anything in the game for like
quite a few episodes um the reason is
guys like it this is what this is what
came programming looks like like it's
not like you write one line of code you
you know you hit control s you watch off
the game and it's completely different
there's like hundreds of lines of codes
they get actually get written before you
see a physical change in the game um
that's that's just the case so I'm sorry
if you guys want to see instant changes
then maybe this isn't for you but um you
know that's just the way the games are
made you know you can't just expect to
see a change every every like every
method or so it takes takes a lot more
than that um especially you know when
we're trying to actually make a game
like purposefully not trying to just
animate something on the screen because
if you if you were doing that you'd have
you know a lot of changes going on but
um yeah so this time we're actually
going to take a look at how the level is
going to decide which tiles are going to
get rendered so there's a render there's
a render class here so in our class
method those render method here in the
level class now
make none of this we're not in the
random level class that extends level we
are in the parent class we're in this
that were in the superclass when the
when the level class all right now over
here in this friend this render method
we're actually going to write code in
here because the way the random levels
are going to get rendered is exactly the
same as non random levels going to get
rendered right we just have to get
different tiles basically or in one case
we need we need to render when you
actually generate the level at but in
another case we are we've already got a
level
well they're just loading in from a file
but the way the details actually get you
know drawn on the screen that's not
going to change so over here in our
render method when I start typing some
code so how is this going to work um
basically think of it this way right we
need we need a way to sort of be like
alright we're going to start from
rendering this tile on the x-axis we're
going to render all the tiles until we
hit the edge of the screen and on the
y-axis we're sort of all going to do the
same thing when I had all the tiles
until we render the the bottom right
corner so in other words it's going from
the top left to the bottom right corner
it's rendering all the tiles in between
so we actually need to tell the computer
we actually need to tell um you know our
software here which tiles need to get
rendered ok and we're sort of going to
do that using corner pins now if you
don't know what corner pins are
basically corner pins are you know pens
in the corner they're sort of like
coordinates of the core of each of the
corners so what we need to do here is
actually find the two corners and you
know thus we can we can calculate which
tiles actually need to get rendered
because when when when we sort of move
our view obviously that changes now in
this case it's not only a power because
obviously we just we just got like as
many tiles as fit on the screen and then
just this void this blackness around it
but in it in a full map you know
obviously there'd be different parts of
the map so in other words what we're
trying to do is kind of create variables
create four different variables one for
the x value of this one for the Y value
of this and one for the x value of this
1 for the Y value of this because um and
we can actually even if we wanted to
combine them then both to create um
specific ones but we we sort of need
four variables just to define that okay
so let's just write those variables now
so I'm going to call them you know what
they're traditionally called and that is
like you know X 0 then X 1 and then y 0
and y 1 so basically the first X
variable which is X 0 it's going to
refer to the the in most X so that might
be a bit hard to understand so I'll just
open the game show X 0 is going to refer
to
remember we're only dealing with the
x-axis right now not the y-axis so it's
like it's like a vertical line that
we're dealing with like a vertical if
you do math it's like a vertical
asymptote right they can think of it
that way a vertical asymptote is
vertical but the equation to it is x
equals you know something naught y
equals because that would be horizontal
but X and also get used to me mentioning
all the math terms because game
programming is all that math so this
vertical line here X 0 is going to be
legitimately at the zero point now
remember it's always going to be zero or
it's going to be the zero most
coordinate and then that won't be a bit
hard to understand but what I mean is is
going to be the the left side of the
screen all right
so wherever what we're up to in the map
obviously if I move it this way it's
going to change but that this this area
right over here um that will be X zero
that's sort of where we start rendering
X and yes let's just I'll just keep
again at the game minimize as I type
this whoops all right so what is
actually we're going to equal X 0 is
simply going to equal X scroll but it's
not just going to equal X scroll it's
going to equal X scroll I shifted right
for now you guys might be like what why
is it shifted right for now remember
shifted right 4 is the same as divided
by 16 so why god I just hit ctrl w's
will close the tab where were we level
sorry about that guys I there you go
so why are we dividing by sixteenths
remember 16 is the size of our tiles
right and the reason we're dividing it
by 16 is because if we sort of water we
want to do we we sort of want to deal at
a pixel level not a not a um we've all
not not not a tile level right we want
we want to be dealing with pixel level
if we don't if we don't / 16 what's
going to happen is it's going to treat
one value as has you know one tile I'm
just going to happen there is hang on
it's the other way around I always get
confused by this divided by 16 would be
making it smaller yes sorry guys my bad
so ah God sorry this always confuses me
um but it's not hard to to to you know
to diagnose the thing is Divya see
divided by 16 is actually doing like the
opposite of what you think I might be
doing because of what I think you might
be doing divided by 16 is actually
making less values so in other words
we're dividing it into tiles set up into
pixels so what's happening is where's my
console window sorry guys let me just
fix up a new computer I gotta go to
close that console let's just put it
over here and now we can terminate it no
it's not running all right sorry
/ 16 what that's doing is is actually is
putting up putting it up into individual
styles like this X scroll variable
that's going to be where our players as
you know players can be halfway through
tiles players players aren't being
snapped to tiles right they can be in
between tiles they can be anywhere
because that they're dealing with pixel
precision as I like to call it now when
we rent the tiles we want to be dealing
with tile precision because we want to
know exactly which tile needs to get
rendered and which child is already out
of the render distance I guess you call
it obviously this is in three days I'm
going to render distance but you know
what I mean so in order to in order to
actually define tiles we need to be
dealing with tiles of single numbers in
other words this tile right here might
be zero this tile right here might be
six one two three four five sorry my bad
but yeah anyway these tiles these tiles
all have numbers attached to them we
don't we don't want to be dealing with
pixels because if we didn't divide by 16
obviously instead of getting like one
over here we get 16 and if we go 32 you
know 32 48 64 and etc etcetera until it
until it you know gets to get to the end
that's a huge number and we don't want
to have to do that because when when we
actually retrieve our specific tiles
there's no need for us to be dealing
with such huge numbers because remember
tiles can only be 16 pixels at the wall
at the moment but the point is tiles are
16 pixels wide so in other words we
identify tiles by simply saying this is
the tile at coordinate I don't know 1
comma 2 right that will be right here we
don't want to deal with it by saying
that's the tile at at coordinates 16
comma 36 or 32 32 you know we won't deal
with it that way we deal with it the
simple way because well it's simple and
there's no point I was doing that that's
why we divide by 16 so in other words
we're jumping from pixel precision to
tile precision by dividing you know X
crawl variable by by 16 and again we are
using bitwise operators because it's a
lot faster now X 1 will be like the
other side so in other words over here I
showed you guys that X 0 was the
leftmost vertical asymptote I guess
this will be the right most vertical
asymptote so as you can imagine what
will this be right
what will X 1 V so X scroll is the is
the the you know the leftmost so then
what's the rightmost now the rightmost
would obviously be X scroll you know
plus the width of this little screen so
in other words let me just turn out that
well screen just lashed so it would
simply be right X scroll and plus like
the height of our screw I throw the
width of our screen now how do we find
out the width of our screen well in this
screen class we've conveniently our
control clicked on it in the screen
class we've conveniently got a width
error on a high drill which is actually
private for some reason it'll make them
public
I always start sawdust when I'm
programming I always start off with
making things public sorry that the
opposite thing that I always start off
with making things private and then I
sort of change them to public because um
if they're not public you know you don't
want to confuse yourself by making them
public even though you won't be using
them in other classes but in this case
we are making them public so the spring
class we made the width and height
variable public note to self alright so
now we can access it so we've we've
conveniently got these these variables
here which actually keep track of
actually how wide and how high our
screen is so what we can do is simply go
to X scroll plus screen dot width right
and then of course when you / oops we
need also divided by 4 now obviously the
problem here is it's going to actually
do this operation first actually then
take a will because I think bitwise
operators are actually applied after
additional operators I'm not sure why
but I think they are but anyway just be
safe we'll just put brackets around this
so it does this first and then divides
it by 16 thus creating an entire
precision and again as you know sort of
two episodes ago I think it was about
how um what what ever you do an X sort
of gets done for y because we're dealing
in two dimensions so the same thing
right Oh y 0 literally going to be the
same as that and y1 is going to be the
bottom corner or the bottom plane the
bottom asymptote bottom horizontal
asymptote of our over our window so it's
going to simply be Y scroll plus
Perrine heights and of course shifted
right for some of the words divided by
16 and that is it so these these four
variables very important because they
define the render region of our screen
all right very very important and you
know next time we'll move on to actually
setting this disk this offset correctly
to our screen class and and yeah we will
get on with this so until then guys
thanks for watching please hit like
button if you enjoyed the video
get a favorite and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
you